welcome back to another addition to the
gadget lab podcast I'm Michael colori
I'm Christina Bonnington this week it's
all about gadgets for once we have a
special holiday themed episode for you a
salute to capitalism we're going to be
showing you all the different stuff you
can buy for yourself or for your loved
ones this holiday season and with the
approaching of the end of the year it's
also winter which is why we have this
space heater here this is the dyson hot
it's a four-hundred-dollar space heater
$400 my god it must have all kinds of
amazing technology in it for it to cause
that much money it does so on top here
we've got this remote control that
magnetically sticks to the device well
I'm sold yeah so Dyson is the British
company right and they've done vacuum
cleaners and hand dryers and they had
that bladeless fan a couple of years ago
this is sort of a redesign of the
playlist fan but in the sides there are
heating plates so if you're familiar
with the same same technological concept
is the bladeless fan but this one blows
air over hot plates and heats the rim
right and it's not supposed to get up to
dust burning temperature so you
shouldn't get that nasty smell when you
first bring out your space heater during
the cold winter months and because the
the plates are vertical they don't
collect material you know just simple
stuff but if you can see it has these
vents at the bottom it sucks air in and
then shoots it up into the doughnut and
it blows out the doughnut towards you
and the physics behind it is you know
centuries old concepts the venturi
effect the quanta effect where it uses
like a jet stream to shoot air across
the room so it's very efficient it is it
can also rotate and oscillate so you'll
get your whole room warm yeah and the
remote you know you can keep the remote
with you and and you can turn on its
oscillation on and off and I mean you
know it's basically it's like a really
nice space heater that you know most
people would feel would problem should
probably cost a hundred dollars but this
is a four-hundred-dollar product so do
you think it's worth four hundred
dollars I don't know um I think if it's
perfect and does everything I wanted to
do it doesn't really matter what it
costs yeah you know because it's like
you're paying for the lack of
frustration sort of yeah but with Dyson
stuff it's kind of tricky because you
use it and it's really difficult to go
back to using anything else because it's
so well designed but I mean 400 Allah's
for space here I know it looks cool
matches my iphone anyway you can read a
full review of the dyson hot on
wired.com right now and I'm gonna step
out and Christina and John are going to
show you what more stocking stuffer
goodies okay so that'll be awesome hey
John what sort of nifty gifties do you
have for us so what we have here are
some killer star wars themed gifts you
can keep them for yourself you can give
them away but they're all built around
George Lucas's awesome Louvre of Star
Wars stuff and so let's just go straight
into it so these are the top ones are
the Christmas ornaments and so we have
Luke we have the landspeeder we have the
rebel snow speeder and this one in
particular has a little interactive
element come on
it's like I'm watching The Empire
Strikes Back right it brings you back
doesn't it okay and then we have all the
there's beverages here so we have the
Darth Vader coffee we have chewy is on
the ice planet hoth cocoa and then
that's Yoda on some green team right
haven't opened it yet haven't tried it
but does it really matter it it's more
about just having some DOTA green tea
and then sort of completing the whole
edible theme we have this which might be
the sort of like the paste is the
resistance of the whole thing is that
hon and instead of being encased in
carbonite he's in dark chocolate that's
right so it's dark chocolate I think it
might even be Mandarin dark chocolate
and so we're not going to demo it here
we're going to eat it afterwards but
this has sort of been the coveted gift
of in The Gadget Lab office so we're
ready to jump into that so that's the
Star Wars stuff and then you have a
whole bunch of ipad and iphone cases
that are also just inexpensive enough to
give away to someone you left right
they're mostly in the thirty forty
dollar range someone you care about but
you're not going to buy them a several
hundred dollar iphone or ipad so let's
dive in yeah first off we've got some
fashion cases here we have a
holiday-themed one we have this one kind
of looks burberry yeah it's actually in
partnership with a Burton snowboard yeah
action sports here's one that's a I like
this one it's kind of a like a tortoise
shell look right and then these are the
utilitarian ones so just quickly show us
ahead of these work so this one has a
little case right here so you can put in
your ID or your credit card and keep it
on you and it's also very sturdy so if
you drop your phone it is covered then
this one has a little stand that pops
out so you put your Yule Log on the old
iphone and the whole family can gather
around and enjoy a little holiday warmth
around the eye device and that finally
what are what are these two crazy
looking contraptions oh so here we have
ipad cases and let's see I guess this
one is an origami kind of style one it
folds up into a stand for your iPad and
doubles as a nice hat very fashionable
sort of Jackie O ish maybe yeah here we
have the lounge case from in case and
it's not like a Santa belly or anything
you sit in your lap and it keeps your
iPad comfortable while your I padding on
the couch awesome and then let's see
next off we have this one right here so
it's almost like a huge paper fastener
it does look like that huh it kind of
like a I feel like a waitress holding it
also but you can hang it on the wall um
very useful very sturdy and then last
off we have a case that's kind of more
professional-looking it's leather and it
keeps your iPad protected while looking
stylish very substantial and all
affordable gifts that you could give to
friends family so that's it for our
little gifties and now we're going to go
back to Mike with tablets an iPad won't
fit into your stocking but here's some
tablets that will now one of the things
that people really like tablets for are
watching videos and reading books so the
two most popular tablets were seeing
this holiday season are the amazon
kindle fire and the nook tablet from
barnes & noble now these aren't really
tablets per se there are more content
portals with touchscreens and by that I
mean you can do video chat with them and
you can't really run a lot of apps on
them but they're great for reading books
and watching movies and they're tied
into some big back end stores like in
this case in the fires case you get all
of Amazon's content available on here
and in the nooks case you get all of
barnes and nobles content available dead
easy to purchase stuff really easy to
grab a book read it download a movie
watch it and then move on and they're
also very cheap the kindle is two
hundred dollars and the Nook Tablet is
two hundred and fifty dollars this is
the newer smaller and faster version of
the tablet that we saw from Samsung last
year the galaxy
tab 7 this is the galaxy tab 7 plus and
while last year's tablet was a bit
overpriced at six hundred dollars this
one is priced just right at four hundred
dollars and it's a 7-inch screen which
makes it great for holding in your hand
and watching a movie or reading a book
while you're on your commute or while
you're laying in bed it's not really
that heavy and it's quite a nice android
tablet we also have another 7 inch
tablet that's a smaller version of a
previous tablet we've seen this is the
toshiba thrive 7-inch and just like the
samsung it's cheaper than the bigger one
this one is three hundred and eighty
dollars and it is pretty tricked-out it
has a lot of connections in it has a USB
connection hdmi connection it has a
couple of cameras so you can do video
chat you can take pictures so it's a
little bit it's able to plug into more
things in your house which a lot of
people really liked about the bigger
version of this tablet finally we have
the S tablet from Sony this one is
bigger as you can see it's a nine and a
half inch screen it's also more
expensive it's four hundred fifty
dollars but it has this really cool
design feature where it's kind of like a
folded over magazine makes it really
comfortable to hold so if you're reading
a book it's very comfortable you can
also tip it this way and it's tilted a
little bit towards you makes it easier
to type it's comfortable to watch movies
on because the screen is nice and big
and you know it's a has a few quirks
about it that we outline when we
reviewed it like it has a proprietary
connector so you can't just hook it up
over USB and charge it but all in all
it's a solid tablet it's a good choice
that's it for this week happy shopping
we'll be back next week with more news
and more gadgets from the gadget lab see
you down the road
you